[Music]
hey we've got seven years to go folks
you know little we got a long time to go
he gave us a sneak peek at CPAC the
president is not only making America
great again he's gonna keep it great
with another run in 2020 and today we
learned who's going to take the helm of
his re-election bid his 2016 digital
director Brad parks Cal was named as
campaign manager he first worked with
the Trump Organization then helped bring
the president's campaign to victory and
went on to lead digital strategies for
the RNC some exciting news for Trump
supporters okay so Dana this is very
early in announcing the reelection what
do you think the strategy behind that is
I don't know oh I mean all right I do I
know go ahead I'm teasing go ahead go
ahead
well I think everybody knows president
Trump's going to run again I mean he's
it's not the first time that he but CPAC
wasn't the first time that he's hinted
at it in fact he keeps talking about how
the media will even though they can't
stand and they're gonna end up voting
for him so they can continue to have
good ratings I do think that the it
could have been something that you just
structurally they wanted to say he
wanted to send a message saying I
already have my person so stop bugging
me like stop calling me and telling me
that you're gonna be my campaign
chairperson because I already have
somebody in mind and that way giving
Brad that title now quiets all of that
and they're gonna have their work cut
out for them the the American public
usually gives a president a second term
it's very rare that they don't in our
lifetime there's really only Jimmy
Carter well my lifetime Jimmy Carter and
I was born and so you usually can get a
second term it is the path to the
electoral college is what's so important
the popular vote is going to be
difficult for the president to get he
didn't get a last time but he was able
to get the electoral college if
Democrats are super invigorated but they
also are gonna have a probably twenty
candidates maybe more that are going to
basically water all that down and what's
different this time is that President
Trump will have a record to run on so
it's not just I might do this I might do
that it's that I have done these things
and if you are a Republican a
conservative you should be happy with
these things
and that's going to be tough to defend
it's better to be on the attack
constantly the other thing that this
does is it allows President Trump to
continue to define himself before other
people to find him for 2020 and he can
spend his time defining those other
people in the ways that he does by
calling Gregg you're just happy he made
the announcement because you wanted some
fresh news exact top of the show but
just before I get to my main point why
he did this the name Brad parse scale
isn't actually an anagram for red
cabal's rap so he's definitely a Russian
spy a red running a cabal to wrap up
another election okay
all right glad you got to the bottom of
that exactly I get to a bottom hole to
get to the bottom of a lot of things
Kimberly and here's why this matters he
is thinking beyond the sale people are
thinking about all this pollution stuff
you know think about this he's saying no
we're talking about the election he's
thinking beyond the sale it's like you
know when you win a real estate agent
takes you to a house that's a little bit
out of your range and you walk into one
room you look and they couldn't use this
is this is definitely your home office
so they're thinking beyond the sale they
want you to be in the house
psychologically this is a perfect bonus
room for your pool table of course bonus
rooms are terrible because that means
relatives stay so never get a bonus room
you just get a bonus relative it's oh
it's essentially trying to look behind
whatever present conflict there is if
you're in a fight with your spouse you
start talking about the trip you're
gonna go on for your anniversary
so you're thinking assume you're
thinking always beyond the sale and
that's what a Salesman does to get to
get them to move beyond and the thing is
it works because now people are gonna be
talking about this are interested in
this guy hmm
they're interested in the strategy the
fact that he's going to be implementing
a social network strategy again which is
very controversial but very winning and
and and is really important so he's
changing the gate this is what salesmen
do and as Dana mentioned Kimberly he has
a very large field in front of them
there's going to be a lot of names out
I mean how do you think that is going to
impact the re-election uh it's probably
a little easier when you're running
against such a crowded field yeah I
think this was a very smart move it
doesn't surprise me that he did this I
heard that they were gonna make some
kind of you know announcement get some
word out there because also the midterm
elections are coming up this really
Shores up the base and saying okay let's
get fired up this is a president who
despite what people were trying to say
wants to run for re-election he's not
you know tired of it and being president
frustrated he actually wants to keep
doing things and having accomplishments
including winning another term so this
way you can go out and have his
surrogates as well you know campaign
essentially fundraise go out and support
the people they need to win reelection
in the midterms and really kind of shore
up the base also it kind of takes some
distraction away from these other
investigations because like Gregg says
he's saying okay we're gonna get through
this because bottom line is I'm running
and I'm gonna win again and Juan
Williams had a very provocative piece
that was all over the internet the other
day you think three prominent black
female Democrats can take out President
Trump in 2020 well I think they have the
capacity and that would be Oprah Winfrey
Michelle Obama and then I mean those two
are really extraordinary celebrities
their their political standing is a
subset of their iconic status in
American society
kamilla Kamala Harris that simply has
the big pockets of California behind her
but in all three cases what's
interesting to me is that you have women
as kind of president Trump's you know
kryptonite and so women overwhelmingly
black women Latino women and I think
it's 43 percent of white women voted
against Trump so you get a strong iconic
female figure and boy I think that's why
Crump went after her Ronnie you left out
Maxine Waters why did you do that she's
an icon
are you a just is that what it is if you
get into a trend if you're gonna do a
trend well look if you're in love with
Maxine I'll talk but here's the thing I
think that President Trump is more
interested in running a permanent
campaign and that's what he's doing I
think President Obama was a keynote
doing the exact same
no comparison I mean President Obama
didn't announce that he was running
until it was like two years before the
next campaign
this guy announced on the inauguration
date by the way I know for everybody who
read The Drudge reporters watching it
show the old president Trump just
announced that he's went on inauguration
day he filed papers announcing that he
was going to run as co-chair Obama was
rolling for less there's no comparison
in terms of the time period but the
second thing to say is that when you
look at Trump he has raised 43 million
dollars in the last two years that's
four times more than Obama raised in his
first two years so you understand this
is a permanent campaign he's not he gets
a kick out of running he loves the
rallies remember after the November 16
election he was holding rallies he had
his first campaign rally for 2020 a
month after he was an author telling me
that President Obama wasn't in love with
campaigning he was a amazing campaigner
and a terrible leader I don't think he
was a terrible leader and obviously you
got like big knocks on President Obama
who said he couldn't manage the
government very well and when he wasn't
on the ballot his party suffered he was
a great order and he loved giving these
speeches if I was to draw a bottom line
on what he did today I would say one he
loves campaigning he loves the rallies
that's when he's at his happy he's not a
governing guy but the second thing to
say is hope Hicks was before the House
Intelligence Committee are we talking
about what's going on with hope Hicks
talking to investigate no we're talking
about the distract well speaking of
investigations day I think Jeff Sessions
Locke said that he was going to open up
an investigation into FISA abuses under
the Obama administration I think it's
just basically investigation warfare
going on at this point is this going to
do anything
well I the investigation that a sessions
ordered will fall under the Inspector
General Michael Horowitz who has his
hands full he's got a lot of stuff to do
one of the trey Gowdy was on the daily
briefing today and said that he welcomes
this investigation but there could be
other needs for investigations at
such as the State Department if in case
this investigation that they're working
on now turns up other funny business how
was Trey Gowdy's hair okay Greg what do
you think about an investigation gait I
am I believe there's an investment
vestigation gate gate and that bothers
me no I was just thinking about
announcing that I'm going to be running
for re-election before I actually run
for my first election wife I don't know
just for the heck of it I already I I
want my library to be in San Mateo
California across the street from Serra
high school okay knock down anything yes
you got to knock down a lot of stuff my
library ribs
they'll be free rib they'll be free ribs
and notebooks okay Kimberly sessions
looking into the files abuses
this whole thing's boomerangs on the
Democrats if you asked me we have an
unmasking memo that's about to drop and
that's not going to be pretty for a lot
of the Obama officials allegedly
involved like Samantha power and Susan
Rice do you think he can make any
headway or is this gonna just get lost
in all the text memo investigation
kerfuffle I think people are going to
pay attention to it because there's been
quite a lead-up you know to this point
and there's been a lot of vocal pressure
and you know in the media and from
people and from Trump supporters to
examine this especially given the fact
that Democrats started this they opened
up this can of worms and made these
accusations and now this is follow
through and follow through eventually
leads to justice so we'll see here what
happens he's doing his job he should be
doing this he'd be derelict in his duty
if he did not follow through on it and
then what we need to do is cover it all
right one last word well I just love
what Kimberly sent investigations lead
to justice okay maybe we can investigate
sheriff Israel I think